olá a todos sua alta aqui quem fala é o
dar que seja muito bem vindo já mais um
vídeo e o estrago de que não sair não
sei que o jogo trazer hoje levantem-se
implica nenhuma para fazer um vídeo sem
energia sem nada apesar de notar se
muito contente mas reportou que a fé não
é
é eu não sei o que o idt gravar pessoal
por isso primeiro porque encontrar pra
que eu vou fazer vídeo por isso é até já
e volta e pessoal eu encontrei que este
site encontrei um filho e outros canais
até porque eu gosto de copiar é e pronto
e basicamente a partir desta então vocês
já viram que decidiu acertar nada demais
e o que é que este site faz faz estas
crianças
eu não existo agora sua pena de uma t
shirt branca soma de shantou na itália
queria só ver a minha mãe dentro de mim
ó agente um relógio dentro do igt o
processará quem matou leda passará x ao
quadrado vezes dois não dá 34 tipo de
ensinar
eu tenho um colega de turma de por si
mesmo isto meu isso não dá quatro meses
inclui
foi o que não dá não pô não pode por si
mesmo calma não é assim é igual e isto
[Música]
passa na casa tenham tão que alinhou olá
um webgame o estudo esse uso da facale
banco 12345678 foi o inglês voltou
ninguém caiu de cair é tentar fazer
frente às outras
o coala mas agora chegou a marcar um gol
o que está bom e parece calma e doce
mais meu isto é um passo é conseguir
juntar a minha cabeça com meu corpo
homeopático de conquistar em nada
perturbará
o atesta as boas sim se irritou o boca
também olha às vezes a gente porque
nunca contou fazer isso não é o que
parece a 1 com um gol
o tempo é o que o milton bogado amigos
só vai me ouvir a resolver uma problema
de matemática
acha que pode chegar aqui com lucro
[Música]
isso não tem piada porque são só guardo
em mim nos 44 vezes a gente não tem
piada assim
olá o outro da palavra amigo eu tenho é
grande pois nem meu colega e amigo tenha
se comprometido da nossa agora só não
resolvem nós porque nós somos dois que
olhar onda a onda quando vocês fazem o
extremo só contra vejo a cheiro pelo
gmail dentro que kolb fx lá o fundo tem
sempre que o que ele é um cara que sabe
quando assistiu com cinco gols e vencer
sabendo acho um caracol e vem aqui o
rasto de coque roll é eu estar de volta
em todas buscar o fundo e quando você
chuta uma engorda de cara qualquer
[Risadas]
por isso os animais que já não lembro
quem é meu
isto não tem piada porque é só cor de
coisas que eu botei de voltar ao normal
então é isso pessoal nós vamos ficar
porque com este vídeo já ia dizer
episódio mas não é um vídeo totalmente
renda
espero que tenham gostado pessoal ano
hoje não a si mesmo fazer um vídeo de um
jogo específico por isso vim pra que a
vacilar e ver o que sei eu acho que até
ficou engraçado pela maneira como editar
o vídeo mas é isso pessoal
espero que tenham gostado de chuvas
forte apoio o aik favorito fiquem bem e
tomem café é porque foi é vida